votre lapin semaine sont venus en masse
sur suivant
non mais avant l'été comme un gogol
avait quelque chose à récupérer avec une
parents sont encore avec des gants la
manière importe peu
le plus important aujourd'hui pour les
dalones de l'académie c'est de nettoyer
une partie de la plage de saint paul à
proximité de l'embarcadère unis de cette
plastique de différentes couleurs pour
les différents déchets ramassés encadrés
par des agents de médiation du tc au les
jeunes filles se sont mises au travail
ça s'est déplacé bouteille donc on va le
mettre dans la poubelle bleue
la nouvelle audi a les bouteilles en
plastique transparent la canette en
aluminium ballack ou d'âge
normalement ça ne doit pas scoré sur une
plage ça ne pas se retrouver dans une
poubelle sachets plastiques bouteilles
cartons usagés
à chacun son sac car ce petit bout de
plages où la baignade est interdite et
très fréquentés on y trouve de tout ce
qui retient néanmoins l'attention ce
sont les mégots de cigarettes est là
tous les records sont battus en très peu
de temps
les bouteilles sur en caisse on a fait
une campagne de sensibilisation a
distribué des
des cannettes et
des petits supports pour les mégots de
cigarettes sauf que bon ça sert pour un
jour mais on s'en occupe
par la suite on préfère cacher ses
mégots en dessous du sable que de
ramener ces déchets automatiquement la
maison c'est un geste qui est devenu 5
pour la population mais qui engrange
beaucoup de problèmes pour l'aventuré
faire un acte citoyen ou nettoyer en
espèces mais surtout prendre conscience
des enjeux environnementaux académie des
dalons met un point d'honneur à
inculquer des valeurs à toutes ces
jeunes filles de cette 9e promotion
s'inscrit totalement dans l'esprit de
l'académie des talents à ça entre dans
le cadre de nos ateliers citoyens éco
citoyen on accueille des personnes qui
sont motivés responsables impliqués seul
fonctionnement de leur île et ben c'est
des personnes qui ont envie de montrer
sensibiliser la population sur la
préservation de notre environnement pour
n'être il a et fabiola cette matinée est
importante car il faut absolument faire
attention l'environnement dans lequel
nous prenons les joli tout ça et et
l'environnement il doit être beau edward
est propre
en fait que nous fait cette action là
pour que l'environnement il j'aurais un
peu plus ce qu'on a comme nos enfants
ben quand il grandit belle cette voie
que ça nous l'a fait et de est de plus
en plus que havas grandi zavaro fait la
même chose on est en train de ramasser
les mégots de cigarettes
enfin il ya plusieurs équipes ya
ramassage mégots il ya aussi
le recyclage des bouteilles en plastique
et où il ya aussi la poubelle jeunes les
tout ce qui dieu
les barquettes manger tout voilà c'est
important ça de faire ce genre d'action
oui c'est enfin si pour nous mêmes c'est
pour ces pour tout le monde aussi
six autres pollutions et de piercings a
rappelé respirer après 1h30 de travail
une première pesée des déchets révèlent
des chiffres impressionnants plus de 6
kg de déchets qui seront à enfouir 1 kg
de déchets recyclables mais surtout plus
de 2000 mégots de cigarettes 2000 les
mégots reste donc le point noir de la
pollution aux alentours des plages
puisque ce constat est également valable
pour les plages de la côte ouest qui
autorise la baignade un vrai changement
de comportement des fumeurs s'impose
salut qu'à lille mais joli